I'm Jesse Phelps and this is Jessica
Ellis see november of last year I had
been chatting with some people at
another conference on tech tech stuff
and indicated to them that I was
interested in using technology with
agriculture and trying to do some
small-scale applications of that and
ideally eventually get to helping urban
farming applications do some things and
they introduced us because Jessica was
Jessica's in charge of a healthy
lifestyles program at the Boys and Girls
Club in San Diego and they have a big
garden there and they were looking to
apply technology to it as well and start
introducing kids technology in that
vehicle and so we got together and have
done a few things and this is just kind
of talking about what we've attempted
what we've learned and what we're trying
to continue to do and where we're going
with it so fewer than ten percent of
schools offer any kind of computer
science curriculum today and less than
one percent of students actually attend
any of that and a part of an
organization that were involved with as
well teaching kids programming is how
all of the tech stuff started getting
involved with the boys and girls club
really and we're trying to produce
curriculum to help change this and the
farming application of that is it's
really about applying in different
context to the programming rather than
just program for programming sake it's
let's use it for something else that
kids might be more interested in in
their everyday life already the this is
the user group that's act the Boys and
Girls Club in San Diego now and all of
these teens are attending fairly
regularly and they attended 30 hours of
java programming just over the summer
second summer and they all came back the
following session as well so the
retention rate has been a hundred
percent for us with what we
been doing and in the actual activities
we're doing with them it's all pair
programming and mob programming so
they're all actively engaged with each
other just as much as they are with the
technology and that seems to be a very
critical element of keeping the
engagement up as well the as you saw
there they're all in the kitchen as well
and healthy lifestyles program does does
the farming they teach how to cook and
it's it's again it's not it's not about
to technology itself it's about life and
technology can help make that better and
that's really the vehicle through which
we're going at it so I have three sons
and jesse has three sons my three sons
are teenagers though and one of the
things that I had noticed was that a lot
of the coding events that were coming to
town were girls only coding events and I
actually called some of the girls coding
events and said I have boys who are nice
to girls can they come and I was pretty
much told no and and I really don't see
how that's going to solve a problem that
we all seem to recognize as a problem
which is normalizing the idea of men and
women and boys and girls coning together
so we sought to normalize that and our
first step was in summer 2014 we ran a
camp called Barbra code which was half
computer programming and half Greek
barbecue cuisine and when we put the
registration out for that we had thirty
eight percent of the registrants were
boys sixty-two percent were girls but of
those sixty-two percent I heard from
every single parent to make sure this
was for girls it must be okay because
you're cooking you must want girls there
because there's you know this other
thing and all of these parents really
wanted their kids to be their girls to
be exposed to programming but they
didn't want him to be the only girl
there and so so the girls showed up and
this last summer it was seventy percent
girls and I got no phone calls so the
girls went to their schools and said
what they've been doing and they were
all pretty much rock stars at ours that
hour of code in December but we our
whole point is to make it just seemed
normal to them we do not emphasize to
the kids you know look what you're doing
or go see if you can code with girl or
anything like that and so we have no
rules about it as you will see sometimes
the girls get sick of the boys and they
kick them out of the room and they take
over and the other thing that you will
notice in this picture too right I don't
know why he's making that face that's my
my oldest my middle son is is it's at
the top of the picture and then samantha
is the girl standing and those were our
to computer programming camp counselors
for camp they were 15 the first summer
they did it and 16 the second summer
they did it and the kids learning from
from teenagers a few years older than
them made all of the difference they saw
it is so much more accessible and I
really think it's because of those two
modeling treating each other
respectfully while still teasing each
other well you know while still acting
like teenagers they got to see a boy and
girl have great respect for each other
and their abilities their technical
abilities while still just having fun so
these are two of our girls Tristan and
Katie and that was two thousand summer
2014 and summer 2015 and they are
training right now this school year to
be our camp counselors for summer 2016
and neither one of them had any computer
programming experience when they started
both of them just lit up at it and this
last summer was when they asked us you
know next summer can I get a job so I
don't know what either of them will do
in the future but their very first
summer jobs from there when they're 16
years older going to be computer
programming camp counselors and I hope
that that inspires them to continue
doing what they're doing
so in the as I mentioned earlier we're
trying to bring technology to a context
that the kids are already engaged in and
here this is the garden at the Boys and
Girls Club and they are already actively
involved in planting and raising crops
and in learning about what that is all
all about and they're also very
interested in world problems and things
that are going on and the question that
was asked is aren't we out of water
because this is in California and so the
kids were concerned about what's going
on in their world and they are looking
for vehicles to which they can make a
difference anyway I mean you know Neil
deGrasse Tyson talks about kids all the
time are not the problem kids are
naturally scientists we teach them to
stop being scientists and so the kids
have questions and they they want to do
things to make a difference they just
are often not sure what to do and all
you have to do is just empower them a
little bit and they'll take it over and
run it after that and that's what you
see with all of the things we talked
about with these the camps we gave them
the tools and now the kids run it and
they propagate the knowledge among
themselves on their own without us
having to intervene too much so when
they asked the question of aren't we out
of water and this is actually right
around the time that Jessica and I got
introduced to each other and this was
the first thing that we wanted to try to
do with the kids so we decided to do a
project where we would actually monitor
the soil moisture content and control
the watering system not based on just a
timer but based on the needs of the
plants so when the soil moisture content
was low enough we would trigger the
watering system for a period of time and
then you know cut it off after that and
the only time we water again is when the
soil actually needed it and I'm not like
a you know an agro science guy don't
work I Monsanto or anything like that
I'm just you know I do software
development as a day job and you know
play with other things on the side and
so we may not be doing if any of you do
work at Monsanto you may laugh at what
some of the things we're doing here
because this may not be perfect but it
you know helps the kids get the idea
and you know think about how to solve
the problem so this is a picture of an
Intel Edison and we chose to go with the
Intel Edison for this initial project
because it had Wi-Fi built onto it so
it's easy for us to get access to a
network connection and deal with all of
that and this particular Edison breakout
board will emulate the Arduino and
Arduino being fairly well established in
the community and having lots of support
around it and lots of modules and
add-ons as you can get for it we wanted
to go this route because there would be
easy opportunity to build on it but what
we found and this is this is the code
that we had for them to have to write
and all we're doing here really is
there's a library for the moisture
sensor right rather it has a sensor in
it reading the capacitance of the soil
and as the moisture content fluctuates
the capacitance between the inner probe
and that outer casing fluctuates because
the conductivity of the air between them
will fluctuate and that's really how
this works is just measuring that and
this is a fairly expensive way to
monitor soil moisture it's a lot easier
to just use a resistive measurement but
that's a little less predictable and you
have to calibrate it and all those types
of things so this was just nice and easy
you just stick the probe in the soil and
you get a good reliable measurement and
there was already a library available
because of the existing Arduino
community to facilitate using this
sensor very quickly but getting this set
up the code wasn't the hard part for the
kids it was actually all the other
environmental aspects of getting it
working getting the software installed
and getting it set up and figuring out
how to talk to the Arduino and and all
of those other things were really bigger
impediments than what we had kind of
anticipated they would be we thought too
much about making the code simple and
not enough and I guess I should also add
one of the one of our goals was we want
to be able to go home and do this again
so if they if they were interested in it
and wanted to build it again and add on
to it
was one of these he wanted so the the
idea was to show them from the ground up
starting from nothing how would you get
this up and going and all of that setup
work was far too involved the code was
actually not not a difficult thing at
all so we kind of consider this to be a
failed project but we learned from it
and this is just a quick sample of the
output that they were generating here
and the goal in this initial phase we
were going to iterate on this and move
to you know controlling the watering
system and but we started with just
getting the text output here of what is
the actual temperature and humidity of
the soil and this just shows you a
sample run where the soil needed to be
watered and then it starts getting
watered and now your humidity level goes
up so the one of the things we try to do
with this as expanding on it with the
kids was we wanted to have it tweak and
indicate when the soil needed to be
watered and so we had some silly phrases
like you know the kale needs watering I
don't know what else we had off pop my
head but actually one of the problems we
ran into with this and we had to pull it
back out of the application with the
kids is the Twitter API is will not let
you repeat a message the same message
within some time window so if you tried
to say the same thing within you know
three or four days via the API it denies
it as a duplicate message so then we ran
into what will add different messages
and see you have so we added different
messages and then we ended up just
having a stick an increment Iran the end
of it so that we could get the messages
to go through so there's anybody who
works at Twitter who can get us
unblocked with that that would be
fantastic because we have these
applications want to do with these kids
but we have to do silly things that that
make it more difficult to explain to the
kids you know we have to say well we
have to add this code on here because of
the twitter thing and it just is
cumbersome so so we learned from this
experiment though and we started
investigating other technological
platforms
and one of the ones that we found is the
electric imp and at this point Jessica
will talk about what we did with that
I'm going to go back just to give them
props so this is this is our windmill at
the farm and it was actually installed
by the HP engineering team it's 23 feet
tall and cox communication it has turned
it into a Wi-Fi tower so that's how we
have Wi-Fi in the farm and the kids
thought they were unbelievably creative
when they came up with the tweeting
windmills handle that was a 12 year old
that came up with that and so we we we
love our windmill he will tweet more so
like jesse was saying the Intel Edison
it was hard and it required a lot of
soldering which at the beginning IOT
device to bring in a soldering iron
which caused me so much pain and all the
install we needed something that was
quick and fast and delivered quickly and
and so we came up with the electric amp
Jesse had had played with it before and
so we tested it this summer and we have
now had 84 different kids do their first
IOT project on electric imp and it has
yet to not thrill everybody so i'm going
to show you if you're not familiar with
the electric in this it's a company out
of santa clara and that little card the
devil they love that to the little devil
sign on the card but it has the little
card that you put in the little reader
and plug in and so this is how fast it
is for the kids they take it out of a
package they plug it in they plug it in
just for power and it immediately starts
blinking colors so they're ecstatic
immediately and then it gets even cooler
because you have to hook this up to
Wi-Fi and how you hook it up to Wi-Fi is
an app on your phone or your iPad app
called the blink up now I'm going to do
the blink up if you are prone to
seizures then you want to close your
eyes for this part and it looks like
this
and now you can see that it's green and
that means that it's hooked up to Wi-Fi
so they pretty much love that
immediately as you might imagine perfect
so even better the idea is a browser so
there's no install at all they're up
immediately how can I see the things
yeah so this is actually from our last
camp you can see they named their
devices very interesting names and we
taught them a show here too or no well
you know what we did the duplicate thing
and it was bad oh right right we try to
duplicate the display earlier and it
crashed the laptop so so how am I gonna
see that fills your neck over there but
I can the mouse is not doing it there it
is okay so I'm in it go down to does
that say what does that say sea dragon
okay so open that up and I'm going to
build and run this code and as you can
see it's basically three lines of code
repeated and if you look around the room
you will see a lit up electric amp
showing blue and white LED lights
somewhere in the room indicate if you're
the first to see it it's over on the
trash can so that's the coolest thing
about the electric imp is that it just
needs to be plugged in somewhere and you
might ask well okay so you've used turn
on some LED lights what are kids going
to do with that well if you're my son
you come up the very creative idea that
you're going to set this on the kitchen
counter and when you would like your
mother to deliver food and drink to you
playing Minecraft upstairs you'll turn
on the light and he actually was willing
to come up with a color-coded system for
me so he so you know if the blue light
I'd like this it was a white light I'd
like
his mother doesn't respond to it but but
if you can get someone to respond to
your LED lights sitting on the kitchen
counter but as you can see I took it
from package to lit up lights pretty
fast they only had to plug in a
grounding wire a resistor in an LED
light and we did this actually as an
activity with 10 kids paired you know so
we had five electric aunts one computer
and so we added a element of risk to it
because we had one computer with a
projector that was the name of all of
their different imps and the rule was
once you press build and run you
couldn't touch the computer again so we
got to hear great things all day like
it's a hardware problem know your codes
not working you know well it worked on
the other machine well you know and it
was it was fascinating because every
time they push build and run they had to
go back and make adjustments before they
were allowed to come back to the
computer and and they loved it so the
electric imp is our go-to IOT device
with kids and I have and this is what
we're going to be using at the Boys and
Girls Club this year jump on just some
of the tech details on the IMP if you're
familiar with any of the protocols of
hardware stuff supports i squared seized
by the IMP has basically everything you
would think of built into it supports it
on there are there are five pins that
you can use for i 0 on the end and every
pin will facilitate spy I squared C they
all have pulse modulation on them they
all do analogue out as well so it's a
quite powerful little platform for the
25 bucks for the card yep
we're brag about so I don't know if you
guys are aware of the fact that pi day
of the century was this year and you
know we have a kitchen and we had
raspberry PI's so we decided that we
were going to figure out something with
pies and raspberry PI's and the kids
came up with a lot of different ideas
most of them didn't have anything to do
with the pie they were going to cook in
the kitchen and we're going to show you
a video and I'm going to tell you the
story the video before you see it so
that you won't do this and you'll feel
great about yourself the first time we
showed this video there were no captions
you'll see that we have captions now but
there are no captions and we showed it
to a group of 100 programmers in LA and
afterwards they thought it was great and
they came up and they wanted to know all
about what were the boys coding with in
the tech room and I was taken aback
because it's seventy percent girls and
and when the programmers there's this
group of like ten were asked did you see
any girls in the video and they thought
about it and one of them said oh yeah
the girls were baking the pies in the
kitchen and I'm like really like I was
just shocked and and these are great
guys who were so respectful to you know
the women that were there but we go to a
default where we see boys coding and
apparently see girls baking but that is
not the case and so when you watch this
video I hope you see that too
tako
I just have to get for you
I'm it's five all my life do not eat it
don't eat me out poisonous
creating delicious Key Lime and referee
pies and then later we're gonna create
here is your recording something that's
going to go in your actual pie and
you're a program your Raspberry Pi so
and someone gets close to it it's gonna
be like please don't need or drown will
be spilt
so what we had done with the raspberry
PI's there we had the kids working in
Python and as well and we basically gave
him a simple interface too we bought
just proximity sensors they were just
infrared proximity sensors they weren't
sonic or anything super fancy so low
precision but they were able to to give
us the data that we needed when some
motion was detected at a you know fairly
close range and then we put a library in
front of that that the kids used so
really the only number they got back
from that was just the distance that it
had perceived the motion and then they
had to do everything else so they had to
write the Python to determine when
should we play the alarm and what else
they do they had to actually do the
alarm itself they had to make the calls
to have the sound play so there was a
little bit involved that we made them do
but and they had to assemble all the
hardware with it as well now they didn't
have to solder this time it was just all
on a breadboard but they had a lot of
fun with that as you saw and exporting
bit oh yeah the recording as well that
was you heard some of the things that
they're the recordings were there is
definitely a difference between what
ten-year-old boys and ten-year-old girls
will put in their recordings but yeah it
was filtered we didn't show you all yeah
so and then the the big payoff to at the
end was their parents came and all the
kids got to show their parents what they
had made and it's it's pretty impressive
when the parents are surprised about the
complexity of something that the kids
can put together like that was a fun
thing to see the parents dad had
apparently envisioned they heard what we
were doing but they had envisioned
something far far simpler than what we
did even though he did really wasn't
that hard and all the kids had no
problem with it it was a complete
success for all of them so
so I'm just going to talk about really
quick that the other thing that we're
working on right now and developing is
is introducing kids also to to data and
what we did this summer is we did
something called data unplugged because
in order to visualize the manipulate
data you need to learn a lot of stuff
first before you end up with the pretty
picture and so what we had them do to
understand you know data because they
keep they kept asking questions about it
as we had them go out in the garden and
grab kale and basil and then we went to
the grocery store and bought pine nuts
and pistachios and they made pesto four
ways so they were in the kitchen for a
while and they made four different kinds
of pests when they took at home and they
had their parents and their siblings and
neighbors taste test for different kinds
of pesto and then they brought it back
the next day and they started organizing
data and it was fascinating to watch how
kids would organize data we really
didn't give them any rules on how to do
it we introduced them to the work of
David McCandless who's the information
is beautiful guy and showed them how
simple gorgeous data visualizations
could be and then we gave them posted
sin yarn and all kinds of crazy stuff
and blank white walls and had them two
dated visualizations and then we had a
data expert from the community come in
and judge them and one of the things
that was great is is he told the kids as
a consumer if you're trying to get me to
buy your pesto I want that data
visualization but as a businessman
making a you know determination I would
want that one and they learned a lot but
mostly as all of you are part of the
tech community most people in the tech
community when you're doing something
fun with kids if they can be helpful
they will show up most people don't know
what to do but if you give them an
assignment I've never had anybody say no
to me I am at the Boys and Girls Club
which you know everybody pretty much
likes but but I've had so many people
just go out of their way to figure
things out for us and so this is our
contact information if you have any
questions for us or if you have the
Twitter solution that is really
that that would be amazing the Twitter
solution is our biggest thing but we but
we are going to be doing more stuff if
you want to follow our Twitter tweeting
windmill he will start tweeting again
we're starting the new user group
session right now and we're really
excited to see what the kids come up
with what problems they want to solve
next thank you so much for your time
and we'll take questions do you have any
it does solve the problem yeah it's just
but it's not as fun as if it just it's
an annoying you wants to have to explain
to the kids yes that's true anybody else
it doesn't do anything right now it's
there just for aesthetics basically the
windmill could facilitate a water pump
and those things and we've talked about
putting that on one of the projects we
are going to do with the kids is
actually having to measure we're going
to get a compass and put on there and
having to record wind speed and
direction and they're going to have to
do the wind speed determination with
math and everything based on the
rotation of the window this the other
reason we had to go electric imp is that
when you have a 23-foot windmill you can
put because they do it themselves so you
can put kids up 23 feet one time but if
we had to get them up there with a
laptop to change the code every single
time we would have a problem so so that
way we can install a trick imps and then
do everything from the ground yeah oh
did you I'm sorry go ahead yeah
so so this is how we've done it is is
for the summer camps we do charge we do
scholarship kids also but we do we do
charge for that and that has funded a
lot of the equipment but we've also
gotten a lot of donations hmm we charged
for Barbra code this summer the first
summer we charged 250 in this summer we
charged 295 and that's full day for five
days but like I said the computer
programming counselors the 16 year olds
there they're cheaper there they're
cheaper to pay they're the only ones in
this equation that actually get paid and
they get paid on purpose because both of
those kids were willing to be volunteers
but we said no you have a skill that
needs to be recognized and that has been
very interesting to the user group kids
because the idea that they get paid
because they have this skill that has
been inspiring to them and then the
other thing is um we did get a cox grant
for five thousand dollars and then HP is
give us a couple machines but the
Raspberry Pi monitors we used old
monitors like we actually put a email
out and and said does anybody have
monitors because we have all laptops at
the at the at the center so people were
there were a lot of monitors they were
happy to get rid of oh hey sorry there's
both of you are in a line you go good
so we happen to be on school property
the Boys and Girls Club in in encinitas
is where I'm located and where most boys
and girls I don't say most a lot of boys
and girls clubs are on school property
so we're next door to a middle school
and yes so we actually have a meeting in
November to talk to the middle school
about implementation there we really
consider sells a pilot program and we're
trying to you know make all the mistakes
before we give anybody advise on on what
to do next oh can I get him really close
sorry so to be honest I think the
initial interest was that we were they
it was summer and they needed their kids
to go somewhere and we were a fair Trina
were cheaper than surf camp like that
was I do think a big thing a lot of
people we had wanted their current kids
exposed to computer programming so they
were seeking it out there's not a lot of
options for that in sandy I don't think
there's a lot of options for that
anywhere but so it was random we got a
random group but the thing that they had
in common was they had most have had
very little tech experience and they
were all middle school kids and none of
them had it in school
that so the curriculum that we started
with is actually from an another
nonprofit called teaching kids
programming to keep teaching kids
programming dot work it's the same as my
my email address and i do do training
for them i do train on that curriculum
I've trained other teachers and there
are school teachers using that
curriculum and it's fantastic and it has
kids up and coding in three minutes it
uses the intentional method of teaching
coding and so that is that the two kids
brick and Samantha who taught that's
what they started teaching with and so
in the morning they would do java and
the afternoon they would do whatever
crazy thing that we came up with with
all our weird devices and stuff and and
one of the things and i think this is a
common thing for a lot of people is the
failures are just as much fun when it
doesn't work the kids are having just as
much fun trying to figure out why things
are not working and so more fun more fun
they're having more fun lessons learned
harder lessons learned well exactly and
they and they yeah and so they they
don't mind it they don't mind it when we
sit there going huh I have no idea why
this is happening this way and if
anything they enjoy it but I think
starting with a programming language is
the way to go the electric amp used is
squirrel which is awesome because it's
so much fun to say you just say squirrel
to the kids and they get excited but
yeah I'm a big I'm a big fan of just
getting them to do anything but they
need to see pay off really fast
um it's option I mean you could do you
know they they all basically take USB
power of some kind so we can just hook
up that way but then if we want to do
the extra work of soldering on external
power we most of them have a voltage
regulator on them so you can put a 9
gold on them if you want and and it'll
be fine we've thought about doing on top
of the windmill doing solar and we have
once that you know Chris who's an
engineer HP has said he was willing to
take on that task of figuring out
remember not how not just to do it but
how do then show a kid how to do it back
there behind the camera okay
Jesus speak up did we notice the
difference based on the language um so
anything that you're exposing them to is
new in our case and so they have not
really expressed a preference but the
only thing they've really been exposed
to is Java squirrel and Python when they
were when they were using the Python the
Python was the least of their problems
the hardware for the Raspberry Pi and
trying to think of something else
disgusting to stay in the recording
booth was the high priority of that
whole day so they didn't express
difficulty with it but we did make that
as easy as possible because we knew the
hardware was going to be such a
challenge any others yeah
a scratch well um scratch is great I
mean anything's great but the thing
that's really happening right now is
that there are elementary school
teachers who are tackling this issue and
then you get to high school where
basically the first thing if they have
anything it's AP Computer Science and
middle school is when you lose kids and
AP computer science is not popular it's
at my local high school has 2,500 kids
they were running it once every other
year they're now running it once every
year and and the main reason when we
started talking to kids about why they
wouldn't take AP computer science is
they didn't feel like they were
qualified to take it because you know if
you're taking AP bio you've had bio
there's there's more kids taking the AP
geography test than the AP computer
science test right now and we're we're
really losing them is middle school and
so exposing them to just a little bit of
programming you know in a math class in
middle school in anything in middle
school and after school program will
change the way they look at it so that's
the other reason for Java the AP comp
sci test is in Java so the AP comp sci
class is primarily Java there's so much
of our culture that makes technology and
science and math in general seem hard
difficult and you know you have to be
really smart to do it and in that middle
school age range is where you know as
kids start to really develop more of
their social groups and those kinds of
their their activity groups and things
that's where they seem to start to
filter out and avoid you know they hone
in on what they're interested in and you
know there's a natural tendency to not
want to do things that are hard even if
you have an experience that is being
hard if you're told that all the time
and that's what that's what kids hear
from our society about technology and
science and math in general so that's
that's part of the reason why I let's
bring it to the context they're already
in these the kids we had easy access to
we're already in this healthy lifestyles
program they were doing cooking and
and raising crops so it was let's just
apply it's worth already doing and now
they're not focusing on the technology
of although they have come out to be but
there it's augmenting what they're
already doing and they automatically see
that it's not hard but we're kind of
tricking them into doing it in some
sense initially and then they really get
into it and now you have a lot of focus
on the technology what I've observed
about girls in tech is that they don't
need swag bags and they don't need pink
balloons and they don't need on't need
all of that stuff they do want to tackle
serious things but they want to do it as
a group especially in middle school
failing on your own is not okay with
middle school kids but if there's eight
of them and they're all working on
something together and they're failing
and succeeding together then it's
fantastic and and we really watched them
take charge we have both girls and boys
in the user group they are good friends
with each other a lot of them their
preferred person to pair program with is
a member of the opposite sex and
sometimes it's not it's all personality
driven and but they want to solve things
and so for them it wasn't that they were
super interested in learning to code but
they wanted the windmill to tweet they
wanted the moisture sensor to you know
to give back a reading and and that
steams um it's not gender specific but
girls light up at that the we're going
to solve something program for just
programming steak was is it's not as
interesting to me and it hasn't seemed
to be as interesting to the kids that
I'm working with
good all right thank you so much